还是啊只有CEO当经纪人先得到
只有我没有哈哈哈哈
第一批预购跟第二批预购在努力的改改动
给大家
希望可以让大家早点拿到
你答案
各位观众
听得懂的都有点年纪了
阿哲的早睡时间
等他早哎
我觉得要跟阿斗收钱耶
应该要收钱了吧
这个钱多
好歹也要来这边应该还不为过吧
笑一笑
三杯三杯
他这次的酬劳我们就自行帮他扣下来
买东西给大家吃
大家hello
谢谢阿德
不客气不客气
拜
太大声了吧
那拍手那个拍手太大声了
汤圆要给大家
因为今天是冬至
然后再加天射日
一个双吉的数字
这样子这样
所以蛮难得的
然后待会大家都可以吃一点汤圆
那你先去吧
再过于喧
放三路啊
是啊
kiss kup不都这样吗
武汉好快哦
速度很快
大家这几天怎么样快乐
因为有你有好运
好运好运有因必有果
我有心灵
心灵有我哇
哦原第二我就是希望大家多做善事啊
不要做坏事哦
然后呢我有心灵
就是很高兴这辈子有认识心凌哦
荣幸真的是像天使一样的
大家都知道前一阵子光复乡的事情
心里是第一个跳出来做善事没错
然后心里有我就是我要说的是呃
不管发生什么事情
有我们在我们爹地
啊武汉王心凌天使下凡
王心凌
武汉王心凌全场炸裂
林希林
希林欧耶
诶哈哈哈哈哈哈哇
我这上来就跳舞
快乐不会迟呦
吼半天半夜
三更半夜
班哥走
人家呜呜呜呼
本来笑要开嗓子就笑到锁了
我好像抽了一场演唱会
你真很辛苦
♪ 天灵灵 ♪
♪ 叮铃铃 ♪
♪ 赶走所有的坏天气 ♪
♪ 准备和夏天降临 ♪
♪ 常上签 ♪
♪ 好心情 ♪
♪ 叮铃铃叮铃铃 ♪
♪ 呼唤所有的好运气 ♪
♪ 闪电降临 ♪
♪ 注定爱上你 ♪
我想跟大家分享一下哦
有一位我们团队的小伙伴
之前呢这个男孩碰到我的时候呃
就算我们昨天才见面
因为我们在工作嘛
然后他都会对着我说
嗨好久不见
然后我就想说为什么呢
为什么我们昨天才见
你
还是跟我说好久不见呢
他就说因为我的有首歌睫毛弯弯里面的歌词
就是好喜欢你
却说好久不见
所以他就会对我说嗨好久不见
但突然有一天你所有幻他不再对我说了
因为这个男孩在我们的巡演过程中
有了一位值得一生相伴相守的女孩
总要上好怎么办
我们要怎么说
答应他答应他啊
耳边亲亲一下亲一下亲一下
亲妈
恭喜他们
我们的好伙伴九瑶跟尚红数到三
让我们一起说幸福快乐哦
♪ 爱咦爱咦爱咦爱两颗星星 ♪
♪ 一片海 ♪
♪ 牵着的手都明白 ♪
♪ 再也离不开哦 ♪
爱爱爱很感动诶
我没想到其实眼眶有点湿湿的耶
哎哟天哪
刚好像看着自己的弟弟
就是求婚成功
这种感动哎
好好OK
所以不能出来的鱼不能吃的
因为这是你一辈子第一次做的事情
所以紧张在所难免
杨洋真的真的震仗很大
谢谢谢谢